昨日の動画のコメントですとっとさんが
チラッと出ていてなんだか安心しました
はじめ社長も畑に出ないのかな
今回はそのお話をさせていただきたいと
思います今日は肇社長です毎回コメントに
少なからずはあるんですよ和美社長はも畑
に出ないのはじめシャツを叩きに出て
ください始めた外畑どうなってるんですか
ん
さっきになりますよねすいません年不足で
肇社長の端けど肇社長はどうなっているの
かというと全然説明できていなかったので
今回はその話をしたいと思いますねか
もちろん気にしてない方もいらっしゃると
思いますのでちょっとわかりやすく説明し
たいと思います
あそんな重い話ではないです
これぞ
あみ軽い
8以降みたいなのではないんですけど肇
社長の畑っていうチャンネルを4年前に
つくりましてどういうチャンネルかという
とまあなる基本メインチャンネルって僕
だけが工場って出るわけじゃないですか
南果歩と思って上の功罪とか友達とかも
結構面白い人が多くて大地くんとかた
ナッツとか実情を見せたらいいチャンネル
になるんじゃないかなと思って始めした
そんな畑というものを作らせていただいて
最初は4人ぐらいですねと友達の大地くん
と後輩のたナッツと俺とオーディションを
開いて受かったメンバーの傭兵先生ほど
メンバーではじめした上の鳩家というもの
を初めて
まあグループちゃんねるって訳じゃないん
ですけども一応たくさんの人が出てくる
よってチャンネルをつくってコンセプトと
してはみんなと話し合ったり方向性が
ちょっとずつ帰って来たりをしてたんです
けどもまぁわかりやすく言うと俺たちの
日常を写そうというチャンネルとして弾み
者そんな叩きをやって来ておりました
が僕の目標としてははじめ社長がいなくて
も成田とチャンネルを作ろうっていうのを
結構目標にしててもちろん始めたその畑
弾み社長以外みんな素人というか
youtube そんな行ったこともない
し比較も考えられないみたいなところから
始まったんでいろいろを急いでたんです
けども回収地点としては和美社長がいなく
ても成り立つチャンネルを作ろうと思って
行ってきてまぁ色々ありました本当にでも
なんとなく結構みんなできるようになって
きたなと思った頃から僕もちょっとずつを
知ることだったり東京での撮影が増えてき
たりして以前回数というか波戸君出る時間
が減ってきたんですよまあ正直それは僕の
中ではごく自然な流れだした竹ヶ岳として
その遅いどうもずっと作れてるのあれば僕
が手内海とか僕が出ない動画もあっていい
なと思ってたんでごく自然の流れでもう
正直時間があれば出たいんですけども
なかなか出れなかったりメインチャンネル
で東京に3日間のか4日間1週間いた時も
あったり自分ねぇどうなんですけどあの
悪いといい人たちってなんか顔が出せない
日が続いたりしたんですけどもまぁずに
ですね肇社長チャンネルを1000万人が
見えてきましてみんなにお願いして
ちょっと1000万に行くまでは俺は
メインチャンネルね集中したいと突然いか
なくなったわけじゃないですよちゃんと
言って字美里のチャンネルに集中した言っ
てかなり出る回数も減ってもメイン
チャンネルめちゃくちゃ頑張らせて
いただいたんですけれども今何が起きて
いるかと言うとですね1000万人到達し
て北1月ちょっと休止してたじゃないです
か2週間3週間ほどで復帰したときは
ちょっと歌を歌わせていただいたんです
けどもな歌詞の中に畑下のことをちょっと
歌ったんですよそれが事の発端です事の
発端というかまぁ言わざるを得なかった
から発端というかごく自然ではあるんです
けど和美社長の端的に出ようとしたけれど
やる気がなすぎて大激怒気まずくなっ
気まずくなる行きにくくなりましたと
ホコリタケなよこれだけないヘラヘラ生き
てて痛いけど仲間3時ピックの俺の義務畑
がまでついしあえこれはもう生きづらい
っていう歌詞を入れた結果その肇社長の畑
の視聴者さんだったり畑を見てくださる方
もいらっしゃると思います一部のファンか
どういうことだと何が起きているんだと
いうことでちょっとそこでお話が
盛り上がっていろんな水色や憶測風に
シャツは畑を見てたのではないか畑は何を
やっているんだとお互いによくない憶測と
いうか予想がされてたのでちゃんと話そう
かなと思ってきお話いる中でございます
まあまずなんで9勝貼った後にこの歌で竹
の話を出したかというと休んでるのに畑下
にで姉の意味わかんないんだと思ってい素
が少ないんですよ休止してるから案件撮影
だったりコラボだっていろんな事やってた
けど間違いなく忙しくはないんですよね俺
が畑に出れないでて忙しいだけだったから
そこでこんな長いきゅうせき館長に1回の
畑下の動画に出ないのは本当に絶命でつか
ないんだと思ってあのありどんなのお話を
この歌詞ではさせていただきましたので大
激怒っていうのはちょっと肇社長の端的に
大激怒っていうかちょっと思ったんです
けどもう注意はしましたそれも結構前から
どういうの要注意してきたのかというと
ちょっと具体的に誰なんですけどまぁ
簡単に言うと片付けだったり掃除だった
リアたものの管理だったり人のお部屋の
使い方ですねそううちなんかめっちゃ初め
に厳しいやんって覆われるかもしれません
けど
一致を会社なんですねもしこの
youtube っていうのがお金も稼げ
ず仕事にもならずでも自由に楽しいもの
だったら全然をレモン自由にあてがい入っ
てるんですけど一応我々これで生きてるん
でしょ一応我々これで生きておりますで
弾み社長の畑ってついてる以上肇社長が上
にいて正直組織として人として社会人とし
てグループとして
やっぱり責任感のないことをしているので
あれば俺は注意したいなと思うし今後の彼
らのためにもた部分だと思いますけど
どんな会社に入っても怒られるようなミス
なんですよミストになってないことなん
ですよねそれを注意し続けた結果結局
変わらず1000万人到達して俺も
ちょっとひと休憩したからここから畑を
ちょっと盛り上げていこう今まであんま
出れなくてごめんやっていこうって思った
時に未だに畑はそのあんまり変わってなく
てですね動画付頑張ってると思うんです
よって頑張ってるよみんな普通に落ち論
努力はしてるして頑張ってるのは認める
けど動画で写ってない部分が非常に
ちょっと俺はこれは嫌だなって思うことが
多くて針にも畑でとっているお家ってあの
俺が昔住んでた家だったり畑下使ってる車
って誰が買ったのかなって言ったら俺だし
パソコンだったりカメラだってのうちの
会社から支給されているわけでございます
そういうのやっぱりちゃんと使わないと俺
は嫌だなと思ったなっていう感じなんか
めっちゃ丁寧に扱えっていうわけじゃない
んですよ俺もそこまでお兄ちゃんないん
ですそんな起こりめちゃあります木大激怒
って言ったんですけど全然大木切ったと
いうか嫌だなっていう思いを伝え頂ける
あのあんまり僕そういう声を荒げて起こる
ためではないのだからやっぱり
組織として人として
ダメな部分はダメだって言わなきゃと思っ
て
社長の義務としてねそれを言い続けてたん
ですけどいざもとって畑でみんなと頑張ろ
うって思った時に何となくて俺は今まで何
で注意してきたんだろうとか本当に肇社長
とやりたいと思ってるのかなとかいろんな
ことが
頭の中で周りやっぱり肇社長に怒られると
畑のみんなも旬ってなっちゃうじゃない
ですかいやいやシュンってなりたいな俺
ですからというそういう思いもあって正直
行きづらかったんですけれどもまあ今の話
をさせていただくと今は俺が指摘したと
いうか方と指摘されたくもないような
社会人としてというか組織としてできて
当たり前のことが今できてきているように
なってますどうであのその話し合わのやめ
ましょう叩きに起こったとか畑何やってん
だとかそういう話はもう解決しております
それはちょっと伝えなきゃと思って今回
伝えさせていただいておりますだいじ
いやいやそんなの羽田着の中にさせてあげ
ていると仰る方もいらっしゃると思います
がゴム人って12あのー周りのことを気に
せずやりたいっていうんだったらの僕
みたいに自己責任で1人等して全部自分の
責任で自分のチャンネルをやればいいと
思うんですけどそうでないのであれば
やっぱりみんな同じルールで一緒に働いて
一緒に動画とるメンバーが嫌な思いしない
ようにやるべきことをやらないといけない
のかなと私は思っておりますはいという
わけで見捨てたとかいろんな止めており
ましたけどミスってたらあの風にも入れ
ませんから俺は見てるとき一切触れない
名無しそれだった畑解散させるんで俺だっ
て根掘り食べないんですよ起こるように
見えます絶対を掘りだクナイシュアの散歩
ランナーず友人のはじめした長が人の上に
立つなんて俺多分5年前とか想像もして
なかったから動画だけ見ると絶対伝わら
ないと思うんですよその何をやってないか
とか全然から本当に裏の問題というか見え
ない部分で非常に俺はそれはどうなのって
思う事がたくさんあってから注意し続けて
な女て戻ろうと思った時も治ってなくて
気まずくなってけど今も解決して畑の
みんなも話し合ってようやくちゃんと組織
っぽくなってきたということで今は改善し
ているのでそこはもう皆さんなんか
ゆったりとかさんとやるとか言わないで
あげて欲しいなと思っています今本当に
頑張っていますであの
良くなったものの結局出づらいじゃない
ですか見てる人からするとかはじめそれが
起こってて畑に全然出ないっていう情報
しかないからそれはもう肇社長を見てたの
かって思われるし畑も何やってんだって
思われるのは間違いないんですけども風に
一つが起こっのに対して羽田着がどうする
かっていう動画がやっぱ出るのが遅かった
な非常に申し訳ないなと思っておりますが
いろんな憶測が生まれたらどうなってるの
とかこの状況だけ見たらやっぱり初めて3
ているとまるでも仕方ないし畑お前ら何
やってんだって言われても仕方ないんで
そこはちょっと叩きのアクションというか
大切って取って茹でた動画に対しての
リアクションが遅かったからって言う
終わります本当にそこは申し訳ございませ
ん結構真面目にどうしようとか畑のこれは
どうしようという話結構して時間とって
回避っぽい音もしたりしてるんであの皆
さんが思っているほど何か何か悪いとか店
だとかじゃなくて純粋に俺が大激怒って
言った後に急にはたきでてへっやってたら
それこそ何か示しがつかないしその怒って
たのはなんだろってなるし視聴者さんの
疑問が残ります畑下のみんなもあなんか
全然これ仕事しなくても弾み社長怒っても
問題ないじゃんって思われてまた同じこと
が大きいてもやだし正直の畑のみんなの
動画としての視聴者さんに説明する
リアクション町でちょっと動画にづらかっ
たというかでても示しがつかなかったなっ
ていう時間があったよっていうお話です
ございます以上が張ったけど肇社長の現場
になります津波あの畑のみんなが謝りに来
てくれたのでその動画畑で今日上がって
いると思いますのでそちらを是非見て
ください
いやー
人を雇って大変だねぇとってるつもりじゃ
ないけどやっぱり誰かが上に立たないとさ
示しがつかないというか収集がつかないよ
ねばみんなやりたいこととか思っている
こととかあるし勘違いしてほしくないのは
結構あの僕これを持ってるんですけど
幼馴染じゃないんですよ畑でぴスターズと
か10日イオンやトロ com .とか
みんな昔から仲良いお互いのことを知っ
キンタとかも誰もしてるんだろうね
ぶつかり合って分かってやってる仲間たち
なんだけど畑ても外れ社長の後輩始めた
その友達ここももう何なら仲いいかも
わからないでオーディションで受かった
メンバーもいます皆育ってきた環境も違う
しなんだか最近知り合ったみたいな名馬も
いるした分なんだけど最近こいつのこう
いう部分や店ってをボブも出てきたと思う
んでなんか肇社長の畑て仲良しなイメージ
ありますが決してあの皆さん彼は思い描い
ている超仲良し by y みたいな
イメージではない
ですこれだけははっきり言わせてもらい
たいだって寄せ集めだおなんか悪いと言い
たいわけじゃないで何か良いですけども
そんなに仲良くないよっていう感じで
ございますそれが肇社長の畑で砂が悪い
わけじゃないから何か良いよなんかいい
けどよだからその中途半端に何か良いから
みんな注意し合えないなと思って注意し
たら関係が崩れる関係だろこのスレね主は
子注意してくれたウザって思って関係が
崩れるかもしれないし叩きはそういう
ぶつかり合い様を乗り越えて幼馴染ん
そして親友みたいに仲良くなっていって
ほしいなと私は思っております俺屍注意し
ないんだもん
俺を2位したくないよいろいろ情報出るの
が遅くなってご心配かけたんですけども
これが事実でございますね肇社長の畑の皆
には頑張ってと言ってあげてほしいなと
思いますこれもとうとうたどるドアの僕も
悪いです本当に肇社長の葉月を作った時に
は本当肇社長として動画の作り方だったり
こういう動画撮ったら面白いんじゃないか
こういう編集どうなじゃないか動画に
関することはがんばっておせーてきた
つもりなんですけどもそれ以外が全然抑え
られてなかったチームとしての動き方とか
俺も年間肇社長一人でつでやってきた人間
だからチーム力組織力をあげるっていう事
はちょっと俺は昔からできてなくて
ちゃんと腹割ってダメなことはダメって
言い合いないみんなももちろんあるんです
けどそれをさせずに何か動画のこと
ばっかりを追求してきてしまった上司で
あるはず3冊を僕自身も悪かったなと思っ
て反省しておりますムズいねえ
俺した長よりクリエイターなんですよ
やるべきことはこれもホンダね何も考えず
畑に出ないんですよ楽しくヘラヘラとはい
というわけで肇社長は働きに出たくないと
かはないんですけども出にくかったけど
ちゃんとこれで説明してくれたので出
やすくなったかなと思いますとねほんとに
俺が言っていること以外は本当に頑張って
くれてると思うので是非とも皆さん応援し
てあげてくれると嬉しいです
march ホント詳しい話は畑下の動画
であるのでそちらぜひ見てください上に
立つ人間ってこんなに悩むんだなと思って
けどなんか俺これも型社会勉強だと思って
なんか悩んでいる日々ですけども
ありがたいなと思ってあの日々次成長させ
ていただいております肇社長兼社長です
今後ともよろしくでしょじゃーん
[音楽]
blh r そう